[Music]
you
hi everyone its charlie big surprise we
have a first teaser trailer for Lord of
the Rings Amazon series that's going to
be coming in the next couple of years
they're getting ready to start
production that's why they dropped this
as you probably saw during this there's
a couple things that let you know
exactly where the series is gonna take
place what the time period is going to
be in the major events that it's going
to cover most notably the forging of the
Rings of power that big prologue that we
get from Galadriel in the Fellowship of
the Ring from the movies kind of sets
you off so I'll break all these Easter
eggs down and kind of explain what's
going on with the series and the big
characters that are going to be involved
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will be doing Lord of the Rings
episode videos what it gets here but
I'll talk about when I think the actual
premiere date is going to happen based
on what their schedule is right now they
also kind of drop this to let you know
what the creative team is going to be
they just want to let you know that they
have some really hardcore people on the
team Tom Shippey you'll probably
recognize from all the bonus features on
all the Lord of the Rings movies he's
the person on the team that can answer
pretty much any obscure question about
tolki lore or talking himself that you
would want to know and then of course
you'll recognize John how he was also
featured on some of the Lord of the
Rings bonus features from the movies
Peter Jackson went to him really early
on during development of the original
Lord of the Rings movies to start
developing concept art so that they
could give it to all the production
people that were building the sets doing
the costumes so he has a big role in
informing what the series will actually
look like when they start to build it
out well like I said the series is
basically covering the forging of the
Rings of power in the rise of Sauron
when he still looked like this this is
actually his pure angelic form there's a
deleted scene from Lord of the Rings
Return of the King
where Aragorn was going to fight Sauron
in his true angelic form but as Peter
Jackson says it didn't wind up making it
into the final cut of the movie it was
an attire which is a representation of
Sauron as he is as true angelic form not
on the
they destroyed sort of evil force that
inhabits the rest of the film it was the
form he took when he managed to fool the
elves and to actually creating the ring
one of his great powers is
shape-shifting so he can make himself
look like whatever he wants to look like
so there's a really good chance we see a
version of Sauron walking around on the
TV show looking kind of like this as we
see they tell us the series takes place
during the Second Age there was a funny
moment at the TCAs during their big
panel when they revealed this because
someone in the crowd who knew their
talking was like the Second Age covers
3000 years worth of history when is it
actually going to take place the funny
thing is is that most of the important
people during this period are all from
very long-lived races you either have
elves who are functionally immortal
unless they choose to die you have the
númenóreans which descend from elves so
they live way longer than normal humans
like you look at Aragorn here he
descends from the númenóreans during the
events of The Lord of the Rings series
he's over a hundred years old even
though he looks like he's still in his
late 30s early 40s so it's not a game of
Thrones situation where you have
characters who are normal humans aging
one year at a time every year that your
series airs I'm expecting them to use
some of the same storytelling tricks
that they used with the movies where you
book in the series with two major Wars
two major events they did the exact same
thing with the Game of Thrones series
where you begin with the events of
Robert's rebellion that takes place
before the beginning of the first
episode then by the end you have this
giant war for the dawn it's the Lord of
the Rings movies that begins with the
big war at the end of the Second Age
where a sealer is able to chop the ring
off of saurons hand that marks the end
of the Second Age in the beginning of
the Third Age when Frodo finally
destroys the ring of power in Mount Doom
and they finally defeat Sauron that
marks the end of the Third Age in the
beginning of the fourth age so there's
all this history that goes back to the
first in second ages that we haven't
really seen yet what I'm hoping is is
they start the series with a prologue
that's the end of the first stage the
beginning of the second age that war was
the final war against Melkor his forces
were scattered Melkor spirit was
banished to the void and Sauron sort of
filled the power vacuum that was left
he's like oh well my boss isn't around
I'm seeking more power so why don't I
take his place
for about the first half of the second
age Sauron slowly built his forces up
around the middle of the Second Age
you're talking about 1500 years laters
when he started to corrupt the elves and
get them to forge the rings of power so
that's where you get that prologue three
rings for the Elven kings under the sky
7 for the dwarf floors in their halls of
stone 9 for the mortal men doomed to die
one for the Dark Lord on his dark throne
in the lands of Mordor where the shadows
lie one ring to rule them all one ring
to find them one ring to bring them all
and in the darkness bind them in the
land of Mordor where the shadows lie so
Sauron had to disguise himself as an elf
he called himself an ATAR that was one
of his great abilities he had many
powers because he had a little bit of
godlike power but he wasn't quite as
powerful as his former lord Melkor still
very strong still from one of the lesser
choirs of angels the name of the elf
that actually forged the Rings was
celebrant Bor he was one of the elven
leaders of this area here but he also
was this really really great Smith
because they live so close to cause a
doom in the mines of Moria celebr in
boar is actually the person who forged
the doors at the mines of Moria remember
the magical doors during Fellowship of
the Ring speak the words friend and
enter
so the same person that made these made
all the Rings of Power when Sauron came
to the elves he appealed to their vanity
claiming that he was an emissary of the
Valar which basically the gods are the
Angels that shaped the actual planet
itself claiming that they wanted to
bestow on them this great gift and
that's why they needed to forge these
rings about a hundred years ago by then
Sauron forges the One Ring in the fires
of Mount Doom and slowly once he puts
the ring on all the other elves are
alerted to what's going on they take
their rings off but everyone else all
the dwarves all the men are bound to
Sauron now so he slowly starts to take
over middle-earth and you have what's
called the dark years as saurons forces
start to grow more powerful the
númenóreans start to get more arrogant
Sauron was eventually captured by them
he realized that he would never be able
to defeat their combined forces so he
actually pretended to turn to their side
and serve as their great advisor so just
like you saw with Wormtongue in Theoden
he starts to corrupt the númenórean King
eventually convinces him that he'll
be able to attain immortality and the
other númenóreans if they attack the
Valar on the Western continent
one of the biggest rules in the world is
is that other beings like the
númenóreans aren't allowed to set foot
on that Western continent so Sauron gets
them to break that rule they try to
start a war in air Oh God above all
strikes down the númenórean continent he
literally reshapes the earth so the
ocean rises up and swallows it the fall
of númenor was kind of like the sinking
of Atlantis or if you're talking about
Game of Thrones the doom of Valyria you
have this epic Cataclysm that completely
destroys a nation of people but a couple
of them did flee to middle-earth and
survived that's where you get Aragorn he
actually descends from the númenórean
Kings after Sauron is able to get rid of
the númenóreans you have this slow
buildup of his power until you have the
war that takes place in this prologue of
the Fellowship of the Ring the end of
the second age in the beginning of the
Third Age and then the actual events of
the movie during present day so think of
the TV series as saurons rise to power
he'll be one of the biggest characters
on the show they haven't announced
casting or anything like that so it's
all open to theory crafting but let me
know in the comments what you're most
excited for in this Lord of the Rings
series just talking about actual release
date they're going into production next
year early I imagine it'll probably take
them about a year to turn episodes
around most likely episodes start
dropping in 2021 so it's still gonna be
a little while the funny thing is you
may have actually heard about this is
that they had to pay 250 million dollars
to the Tolkien estate just to get the
rights to do the TV series before they
ever started working on the story in
their spending Game of Thrones level
money on their seasons meaning they're
spending a half a billion dollars on the
series before anybody's ever actually
going to be able to see an episode which
just sounds mind-blowing so hopefully it
looks amazing but I will do more videos
as we learn more details about the
series later this year I will be doing
videos for The Witcher TV series on
Netflix you can click here for my
breakdown of that big trailer they just
dropped and click here for my Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
teaser breakdown thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
you guys tonight
you